we did [ __ ] her all the way home from  santa wedding I didn't get a rod Anthony  was a [ __ ] animal huh Anthony was a  [ __ ] face in the neck animal Sodapop  Club the soda pop media so it was full  of the so yeah exactly but that's it we  go to riot cash YouTube no no it's a I'm  sorry yeah yeah sheet metal sex do you  like anal sex oh okay  queasy shot Marvin in the face sure sure  yeah security guard on a jobsite she  politely laughs gives you're tipping and  chip laughs I have ramp it up so  embarrassing the crowd see what their  reactor well you get it there's a lot of  six million in eight people turn it down  professional coming why'd you hit Nick  it's tough to get out of it just in case  yes young and sweet homeless seven he  was I think he was oh this is Neil  Diamond I know it is we asked for Johnny  Cash yeah  eight times no no no he just played a  piece of that to compare ah that's a  good that is I told you that you could  work with men